for the first time in five months this
mother polar bear sticks her nose into
the open air here in the small barred
Islands of Norway she's sniffing the air
because well I mean if you've been
living in the dark for five months your
eyes would sure as heck take time to
adjust to the light
[Music]
she's also checking for predators
because now she's got not one but two
cubs to protect hello world
notice how closely mom looks after her
babies talk about vigilant over half the
cubs born here die in the first year
often killed by adult male polar bears
now the Cubs are growing fat on mom's
milk but mom herself hasn't eaten in
five months and is getting thinner by
the day is it time to go in the hunt
well maybe one last nap in the lair
[Music]
ten days after they first poke their
noses into the Frigidaire mom leads the
way Bell never returned to that den
they've got lots of important stuff to
learn in the world
well like for example what we like to
call lair crashing lair crashing is
where mom teaches the kids how to jump
up and down on the ice so they can break
through to eat the seal hubs below
[Music]
but isn't this just like kids they
forget the lesson and start horsing
around with a reindeer leg
in fact pretty soon they've got a
reindeer carcass they haven't yet
learned not to play with their food we
could pretend we're showing you the
stuff to educate you on how polar bear
mom subtly initiate their young into the
rights of predation through tomfoolery
okay that's part of it that's him well
mostly we're showing it to you because
it's so gosh darn cute
but all good fun must eventually come to
an end
mom rolls in the snow which is how polar
bears dry off of course getting the Cubs
to stop courting hello good luck on that
[Music]